first time i don't know what it is
natasha's brought with us i'm sorry
we've got patricia mike
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to my
channel we are here on winners on a
wednesday every single week i interview
one of my success students who are
killing it in property and this week i
want to introduce you to natasha she was
a nurse she's now quit her job she's
financially free and now she's working
on big development deals with myself i
think you're going to really enjoy this
one so get a piece of paper get some
notes and take good notes because you're
going to learn a lot of good nuggets and
information on this interview also don't
forget to subscribe smash the like
button but hey natasha thank you so much
for coming down to my house
no problem at all you brought a whole
team with you we've been out in the
garden hanging out it's been amazing i'm
not gonna lie this house is absolutely
beautiful thank you very much i
appreciate that so you have got an
incredible story of what you've done in
property but also who you are as a
person why you've done it so what made
you in the first place what was it that
made you want to get into property um to
be fair just like growing up in the area
that i did it was quite notorious and
there was not much like positivity and
stuff like that so i kind of wanted to
have like a space for my own self a nice
space but i couldn't imagine it in that
area so i kept focusing and kept
thinking ahead and then opportunities
just came arise like my siblings they
left to go uni so i had like an empty
room and i thought let me just pretend
to be like an estate agent and rent it
out and it did and then literally
allowed us to live
rent free that is so good what year was
this this was in like 2000 and started
uni 2015. 2015. so you were living at
home and you just rented out a spare
room which then paid basically and
essentially made you live rent free yeah
you know what there's a term for that's
called house hacking and it's something
that i think is an amazing strategy for
people kind of wanting to get started
and what what was it that gave you the
because that was like 2015 that's a long
time ago was that literally what was it
that gave you that inspirational idea or
did you just think i was just like well
to be fair if it just made sense yeah
that would cover the the rental income
at the rental cost and stuff like that
and it just made sense we can save more
money and live a better life right and
where else was the house that was in
brixton okay good london yeah and are
you still living in brixton no i've just
recently moved where are you where are
you living now um so i'm now living i
don't really say
it's still in london but is it a nice
bar it's um the tour will be coming soon
why don't you want to stay out of
interest
is it too nice is it i mean i can't you
know i don't people turn it up to my
area
all right but it's a very nice part of
the
world
all right that's good that's good okay
so that was your first kind of
experience in property then trained to
be a nurse what happened next um so then
after i qualified as a nurse um there's
two things that are important to me
health and wealth and i needed to get
experience in health so did nursing for
a little while
and then i retired and i was making
enough money from property so i retired
at 25. which was like literally just a
few months ago which is just like five
months ago yeah last month
july 5th july 5th but you kind of just
glossed over that part like so what do
you do oh wow yeah you know became
financially free and property that the
purpose of this is is to go over exactly
how that happened sure what you did so
you're at university when did you first
come across like my training videos and
stuff and what
i've been literally like every single
time you pop something to do with
property entrepreneur you literally are
the first person to come up i'm like
when did you when did your first
discussion was probably about 2015 as
well around that whoa yeah
so you like literally been watching me
since the very beginning very beginning
wow and i've been meaning to network but
the only thing that was stopping was the
fact that i knew if you're going to be
passionate about something it needs to
be 100 attention and yeah nursing for me
which was health yeah i needed that
experience do you remember what was the
first video that you saw of mine i think
i think he was doing
quite a few there's quite a few but i
remember you talking to people and
saying something about those people in
school that used to sell and then
eventually they will become financially
free and i thought
that was literally 2015. i can't believe
that so it's like six years ago when i
first started my channel okay so you're
at uni you're a natural entrepreneur you
you're passionate about health you're
passionate about wealth you qualify at
uni you become a nurse talk to me about
that
so the nursing aspect so i knew firstly
there's two important things for me
respiratory and also um
life support so i wanted to get those
two experiences i studied and i started
off in a respiratory ward and it was
very nice learnt everything i needed to
know um looked after patients and gained
the knowledge and then i moved over to
intensive care and that's when the
pandemic took place and for me i was
enjoying it because you know you're
learning early not having fun and that's
what for me i was doing learning earning
and having fun right and then the
pandemic came was on the staff
on the page it was just it was a lot
going on and i just felt
on like unappreciated
and um you know the clap for was it clap
on the thursdays and stuff like i think
it was a wednesday morning was it
wednesday maybe it was a thursday
thursday in my area it was just it just
was a slap in the face really yeah why
was it slapping the face because i kind
of feel like
what happened in the pandemic a lot of
people weren't working and majority of
the nurses were working so that means
they have to feed their family that are
not able to actually provide and eat
food so they need money we need money
yeah so it's like
lady gaga
yeah you need money yeah it's like
that's not going to pay my bills that's
not going to pay my bills do you feel
appreciated thank you for clapping i'm
not going to say it's a slap in the face
yeah sorry i do you know but it was like
you need money yeah come on guys right
so you're working how many hours as a
nurse were you working so the hours were
really long so i worked between um three
to four days eleven and a half hours so
i would start at half seven and i
finished eight pm yeah those are over
like three days or three nights right so
you're working crazy long hours
pay what what kind of what we what we
were earning pay was the pay was decent
you know between two to three thousand
pounds
depends on average yeah normal nursing
salary nothing yeah what is normal
salary two to three grand working crazy
hours talk to me about your first
property deal outside of just renting
somewhere in your spare room oh okay so
my first ever deal was
um it was a residential one i wanted to
just be on the ladder i just wanted to
initially just take the first step so um
came across this two-bed apartment um in
essex like the outskirts of london not
very far went for the viewing and then
um
yeah made an offer it was accepted and
then the rest was history so you just
bought a house yeah did you just use
savings to buy it or what how did you
buy it so the house was really cheap it
was like 170. okay so i had to put like
maybe a 17
a 10
discount
10 deposit down okay and um
yeah just you know uh solicitor fees and
stuff like that was about 20 000 in so
you bought it to live in or to rent out
i went to living okay yeah i wanted to
live in um so what initially i did was
had a lodger that would you're really
into this whole house hacking thing
right so previously
so now you buy a house that's again
smart buy a house
live in it but then you put lodger in
the room which probably paid for your
mortgage i bet yeah so you're living
right for it and you're on the property
ladder yeah that's smart yeah that's
smart okay so what year was this this
was in 2019. so a couple years ago great
and then you thought okay
i can't keep buying houses because i
haven't got the deposits that's right so
so you decided to do rental rents yep so
initially what i did was after putting
the advert up for like maybe
maybe a day or two there were so much
people in my inbox and like asking for
rooms and stuff like there was no way i
could tell these people no there was
literally no way oh wow i was like i
need to go get a property like yesterday
right so you oh goodness so you buy a
house you rent a room out did you rent
just one room out as a toilet
all right so you went two rooms
you were just paying you money how much
how much rent were you getting for those
two rooms honestly so it was it was 600
pounds each room so it's about 1200 yeah
and your salary was two to three grand
so you like you're getting you're
getting closer you're getting close to
replacing your income but that's the
thing it's like replacing your income
replacing a two to three thousand pounds
income is so not difficult
i think i remember reaching out to you
actually i remember had a horrible shift
some
they want to talk about it but it was
horrible and i remember messaging you in
that day in the morning i think i missed
the call from you actually you've tried
to call me back did i what happened it
was a horrible shift and i was like
right i need to get i need to get my
life sorted yeah i just need to replace
my salary in order to just do something
or just come whenever i want to work
what happened in that shift what
happened
it was just it was just on the staff and
you know like yeah just everything was
going wrong i knew i wasn't going to be
able to leave and go home on time so i
didn't leave so maybe 10 o'clock
everything was just you know not on time
and i don't want to leave things on how
did that make you feel
it made me feel it was i was very
anxious very sad very depressed not
happy right not happy with a job on a
happy just in life because of the job
just not being live because of the job
right so for me i didn't get home until
maybe 11 o'clock and i was back that
same night so you called me i've
messaged you
you said to me directly natasha you need
to have a goal what is your goal yeah
and i thought to myself
what is my goal and then it just being
to replace my salary was this on
instagram it was on instagram and then i
instagram called you and you missed it i
missed it if i
if you'd have answered it i missed it if
you'd have answered i would have been on
the course the next day yeah whatever
course she was advertising you'd just be
like i'll pay i'll pay
yeah and you have invested a lot into
yourself just recently i won't say how
much but thousands of pounds into your
education
um
but you also utilize youtube a lot as
well oh yeah yeah watch all the youtube
videos so okay so so you're in a
situation by the way you're awesome i
love your story so the situation you buy
a house yeah you rent out two rooms
totally legally above board and you
don't you don't even have to pay taxes
no no no anything up to seven thousand
pounds is tax free
so you don't pay any tax on the money
which is incredible yes everyone should
do this i don't know why i know so then
you rent out these rooms
you use the income yeah and you can and
and then you think and then but the
rooms you could have rented about 10
times 20 times 30 times everyone's
messaging i want to remember what
everyone wanted actually because it's
right next to a big fulfillment center
right so wouldn't you want to know where
you work of course so then you think
i need to buy another house and make the
rooms out or you hear me going on about
rent and ramps
what when did you sort of first learn
about rental rental and how did that
unravel to be fair i watched your video
oh god if my internet could tell you my
history
all right
so you're ready to rent videos i
remember there was two there was a girl
and a boy i've watched that interview
maybe five times who were like what i
think jess jessica and jordan from
coventry
the leaflet i just kept thinking what
were they talking about the leaflet yeah
and i did the research i just knew
as i said anything that you do you have
to put your all of your passion into it
i'm in nursing there's no way i can do
property at the same time right i knew
if i went over to the property me and
you network gone clear yeah i said let
me finish here but i do want to kind of
do something in between like whilst i'm
still you know just in case i need to
emergency leave a job because you know
things happen i might not even fire me i
don't know yeah
so um yeah i watched that video back to
back all your rent to rent and then
i just went for it literally i just went
for it so your first rental rate
firstly in your own words describe to me
in a nutshell what does rent to rent
mean what is it so you basically you
rent the property off a landlord not
subletting guys because i've seen that
you guys are saying subletting is
illegal yes it is you need to let it in
a company's name right so it's a company
yeah you know you've got staffs or you
know people professionals and then you
rent it out and you
rent it as a corporate let with the
agreement that you're not going to live
in yeah that you're going to put people
in it on short stay agreements that's
the agreement okay so
you got you
found a landlord you offered him a
guaranteed rent yes where was this
property this property was also in essex
two miles another two miles two minutes
wow from where i live how much did you
agree to buy the landlord 600 pounds
that sounds cheap yes how did you get so
cheap because
we basically we i do business with
people yeah i know it's a lot more
difficult with the estate agents and
stuff like that so i try to just you go
direct
where did you find this landlord um so
he on land registry okay he lives in
in wales so what you just saw the house
and looked up the details on land
registry like how did that happen yeah
that's literally it you just thought
that could be a good house was it
it was empty and what happened i took
the viewing with the estee agent and
they weren't really trying to
you you do with them but got you got you
the house was was with an agent the
agent was a bit useless very useless
terrible agent terrible so you thought
you know what they didn't deserve the
commission
they didn't and you met and you then
went on land registry you paid three
pounds three pounds you got the
landlord's dealers and you told him hey
this this agent's offering but let me
let me make you an offer yes and you've
got a cheap rate of 65 a month smart so
what did you learn through that
experience so for me you do business
with people yeah because for me he's
getting his money and i'm also able to
have some passive income from that not
even owning the property yeah so you pay
him 600 600 and then you then
rent the rooms out mm-hmm okay with his
permission on his permission with the
right contract with the right contract
how much rent did you manage to get in
on that property that what happened same
so you just rent out the rooms in
individually so it's like 600 pounds
each room it's the area kind of isn't it
amazing natasha that a room
will often rent out for the same amount
of money as an entire house yes and the
only difference is when you rent a room
you're getting all the bills included
yes that's the only convenience when you
rent a house you've got to furnish it
you've got to set the wi-fi up yes when
you rent a room it's all done it's all
done that's the thing people don't have
time correct people don't have time
because they're working as nurses like
yeah
there we go and you didn't have much
time but you still put the time in to do
this deal
so okay you pay 60 pounds for the
landlord how much is the gas in there
tricking everything like gas electricity
the counter that's like 120 the
electricity i'll be honest like 10
pounds every week
it's it's um it's online so you get the
bills yeah and it waters every six
months or every free month so you might
be talking two maybe 300 pounds
for everything everything to maintain
the house to pay for all the bills 600
pounds of room how many rooms there's
three three rooms six twelve eighteen
so eighteen minus six so you're left
that's how much profit was that giving
you about a thousand pounds about a
grand i know we're sitting far away but
i have to give you a fist pump for that
that's awesome okay so a thousand pounds
a month that's like
that i mean that's close to replacing
your salary i have to do that two or
three times
done
so what happened next so what happened
next was as i'm getting those passive
income yeah i'm just throwing it to the
side i'm just saving it save it because
i want to buy to let and i know you
don't i know initially
you don't need money to make money
you can always invest and find investors
but i wanted this one to be just for me
to say that you know what i did it yeah
i did everything by myself i know it
sounds really selfish but
from a child i've always been
independent from a little child i don't
ask for help and it's something that i
need to
come out of i need to start asking for
help and that's why i'm so happy i'm
networking with you now
because it's so hard but um
so yeah i saved up all my salary as you
you know all the
from the passive income from the
properties also my nursing salary which
is putting it aside until i got to a
really decent amount of salary and was
able to a really decent amount of
savings yeah and i was able to just put
25 in a really good um
really good investment which i knew
would actually
be able to repeat itself right that
makes sense i was going to be doing a
buy refurbishment i got you did you buy
that already yes how much you bought for
so it was 16 i bought it for 16 below
the market value good for you um so it
was going for
so i was going for 350 000 yeah and i
managed to get it for 295. that's very
good whereabouts um so also lakeside
just on the outskirts of london near
essex um more closer to london actually
okay pretty much say london 295 in
london that sounds cheap for hours in
london is that a house or a flat it's a
house big victorian terrace how many
bedrooms it's three where did you when
did you complete on that
so we actually had we exchanged complete
completions this week
are you just buying that now yeah oh wow
to be fair it's been a long-winded
process but i do understand with the
land um
what's it called the owner the landlord
the not the the land stamp duty
landscape
everybody's been rushing to try and get
it completed so yeah i've been pushed to
assign right
295 you're buying your very own house
which you already own a house but you're
buying your very own investment house
no lodges this time tenants
um you bought it for 295. does it need a
bit of a refurb yes i'm going to be
adding three more rooms because that has
not even been touched and the floor
square the square meters
is literally a hundred yeah and if we
add it onto the loft it'll come to be
150. is that gonna be permitted
development so it will be permitted
development nice and now now you're
doing the development training on the
development mastermind so that should be
great okay so how much are you going to
spend on the entire refurb so do you
know what i've heard you talk about
refill and i've seen you put some really
cheap numbers and i was aiming about
maybe between 30 and 40 but i think we
might need to
have a look because you bring it down a
little bit yeah well let's say let's say
it's let's say it's 35.
so that's going to be that 330 is the
total investment what's the end value
going to be
the m value so i looked um
at the sold prices for that area and at
150 square meters um um
so the house is around that site a five
bed just a five bid for about five nine
five to six twenty wow so you're gonna
you're gonna make a lot of profit six
figure site six figures uh profit yep i
was just saying that because you just
went on the training program yesterday
what was the program that was amazing
thank you so much what was it called um
six figure six figure six figure
development no six yeah you even
remember what it was called you just
remembered it was awesome six figure
seven six figure sign right which is
teaching how to make six figure profit
on a deal teaching us how to make six
figures right okay so you've got this
property you've got your rent to rent
did you go and get more insurance i'm
still i'm always in in getting returns
but now that i'm off i'm now that off
now that i've retired from nursing yeah
um i'll actually be able to take
pull up all the opportunities there is i
was actually talking to my friend the
other day and i was like i bought a bike
for like 12 pounds that's worth nearly a
grand i was like opportunities are out
there yeah people are just busy and
don't have time how many event events
have you got so i've got two in total
two now yeah and how much are they
making between the two of them so about
2 400. okay so they're making so so from
just the rental rental loan that's
basically replaced your income yes
you've now got a buy to let you know
financially free what would you say to
somebody that was looking to get out of
their job the way that you've done
because i must say i've got so much
respect for what you've done because not
only have you managed to achieve massive
success in property but you've done it
alongside a job you only quit your job
last month so you've done this alongside
having a job you've saved up enough
money to buy a buy to let on an average
salary
yeah it's really really impressive what
you've achieved um what would your best
advice be to someone watching this
that's wanting to do the same they've
got a job long hours how how should they
go about doing this
sam
i feel like when you say it's an
understatement so i'm going to say it
again one more time seek knowledge
seek knowledge seek knowledge yeah what
do you mean by that so get the training
you need to know what you're doing
because i'm i literally i didn't seek
any and i i'll be honest if i did i'll
be a lot further than where i am today
yeah but it's an it's an experience but
i do i do feel like that's the best
thing you have a book read you know
you're in a situation though whereby you
were doing this through the pandemic
like now it's easy i mean you've been to
like lots of events with me just in the
last two months but through the pandemic
when you were doing this we couldn't run
events we weren't running training
programs so you were having to watch the
videos and and i feel like now
it's easier than it was 18 months ago
yeah the market's popping the market's
booming
but i think you're right i think
knowledge getting the knowledge is is
vital because trying to trying to do
something when you don't know what
you're doing it's like it's like trying
to play game of chess when you don't
know the rules
um so how did you manage to get the
timer because that's the big thing
so
we always get annual leaves and days off
so i would work it with my annual leaves
and try to you know if i was off for
like maybe two three weeks i would know
i would need to find something or i
would know i need to do something in
property i need to extend my learning
within those times so it wasn't really
off or resting it was more like this is
to focus on my future my goal yeah how
does it feel to have
left your job
it feels amazing sam it just feels it's
like taking independence over your own
life
it's it's i can't even i'm speechless
it feels great
yeah are you happier now happier than
you were a year ago
so
i am so happy
like it's an understatement yeah i just
it just feels amazing
yeah
yeah well everything that's happened is
a result of your work you know and i
think that sometimes people are so busy
just reacting to everything that covers
in the day but you actually thought
about the year ahead yeah just didn't
fancy retirement at 65. no
will you be able to retire how old are
you 25 25
25
absolutely awesome
so what's next
what's next so i've just started the
development program if yourself and i'm
so looking forward to it um so that's
what i plan to do hopefully not
hopefully speaking into existence i will
be developing my own plot yeah
i know you were i know you were you've
already got your property that you're
going to be developing and extending
with permitted development rights but i
i have vision for you 12 months time i
know it's going to happen you're going
to be back on here part two saying i'm a
millionaire i've just built this
apartment block from scratch and all
this stuff so i'm super excited about
that and respect as well because you've
put a lot of money into education what
made you do that what made you
invest i was gonna say spend but you're
not spending it's an investment what
made you invest you know thousands and
thousands of pounds into your education
i just feel like i did it without any
education and it was it was it was it
was doable but with the guidance and
someone who's done it and you know
they've made mistakes in that field they
can kind of rectify and help you it's
just a no-brainer yeah yeah yeah so okay
cool final words of wisdom and then i'm
going to wrap this up and hopefully by
the way guys if you're enjoying this
video
please do smash the like button uh i'm
inspired right now and the reason that i
do what i do is is for things like this
for moments like this to be able to you
know give people the tools and see them
go and succeed free satisfying what
would be your final words of wisdom when
you're watching this um
what should they go do right away what's
the what one thing could they do right
now to help them get one step closer to
their goals definitely pick up a book
and read into property or even log into
youtube and do your research um formulas
over feelings yeah and stay locked in
yeah it's fun within i love that i love
that hey guys you heard it here first
take massive action get the knowledge um
you know if you want to come and join me
at one of the live training programs
that natasha's done then i'll leave the
link in the description i hope you
enjoyed this interview i'm super excited
thank you so so much for coming down to
the house no problem with you thank you
for having me
welcome subscribe i'll see you next time